we always accuse the older generations
of being stuck in the mud and you know
not willing to change and we always
accuse the young generations of want to
break everything and that they think
they know more that that's old um uh
what's new is the entitlement thing that
seems to be relatively new there's some
interesting reasons for it um one it's a
very connected generation obviously
because of the internet and they
actually have more awareness of what's
going on in the world and have access to
unlimited amounts of information
obviously but if you think when we
started our careers um we were I think
objectively speaking idiots you know
like we came into the workforce actually
knowing nothing right and so we had no
choice but to defer to those who had
more experience so that we could learn
to advance our careers because we
actually knew nothing and we knew we
knew nothing this Young Generation
that's coming in are starting work on
day one with a knowledge of how the uh
how technology Works how personal
branding Works how social media works
and they're actually bringing a skill
set that sometimes those at work don't
have and so I think what it does is
produced it produces sometimes a warped
sense of value when I show up on day one
for work which is I I think I I don't
think you realize what you're getting
here um and sometimes blinds them to the
fact that that though those things are
true I also need you to learn all these
things and you have no life experience
yet and so I think that the way we
interpret that is entitlement young
people are bringing the sense of
apparent self-confidence to the
workforce learning very quickly that
work doesn't work the same way as school
which doesn't work the same way as your
parents taking care of everything for
you which you don't which doesn't work
the same way we may not need those
skills today we need other skills that
what you find is that it can be quite
traumatic and you'll find that a lot of
the self-confidence that they uh uh show
is actually false and it's actually a
very insecure generation that has that
struggles with coping mechanisms um and
we're seeing that in Rises of anxiety
depression you know uh and unfortunately
suicides as well um uh and lacking those
human skills that we talked about before
so necessary for people to feel
confident in work so I think all that is
required quite frankly um is empathy and
though it would be nice to demand that
they have empathy for us that we
actually have gone through a little bit
and have seen a few things in the world
that's less likely to happen and we're
supposed to be the old or more
experienced ones so I think we have to
lead we have to show empathy that
doesn't mean agree that doesn't mean
that we can't hold them accountable but
we have to learn to try and understand
the life that they have grown up in
which is different than the life we grew
up in and that affects their worldview
and their behavior